- We can't get enough of Ross Matthews.
And I wanted to introduce
him to our amazing VFFs.
Ross, say hello.
- Hi everybody.
Hi, oh cute!
- Who's got a question,
Pamela?
- I do.
- Hi, Pamela.
- Hi cute.
- [Drew] What's your question?
- Hi Drew, well, I wanted to know,
like I do rage breaking and stress baking.
So I wanted to know what
your favorite thing is
to eat when you're stressed out?
- Cheesecake, for sure cheesecake.
Does it ever like end up
looking like this on you?
- Not once, it will get
on my shirt and my shoes,
but not all over my face.
And I don't want my kids
to see this episode,
because they might get
a hint that that's okay.
- Well, I've been known to
be a bad influence before,
but this seems like relatively healthy.
- Ross, what do you eat
when you're stressed?
- Wine.
(audience laughs)
- Yes, exactly.
Well, before we go, in
honor National Sandwich Day
at our friend Jersey Mike's are giving
our VFFs a free sub from Jersey Mike's.
And I'm sure watching this segment,
they're gonna be like, who
decided to say yes to this?
Why did this allowed to be here?
- Can I tell you how obsessed
I am with Jersey Mike's too?
Everybody, my favorite is a number 16,
which is like a chicken
Philly cheese steak sandwich.
Try it, trust me, ooh, thank you.
- I have to say, I am the
biggest Jersey Mike's fan
and I really love a beautiful sandwich.
It's one of life's great pleasures.
And happy National Sandwich Day.
And I just think that I'm very grateful.
You know, when we work with companies,
it really means a lot to me,
I take it very seriously.
And we work with this
wonderful man Brandon,
and we love doing
trade-offs and integrations,
because I like talking about
companies who provide people
with stuff that's in their life.
And I'm always really
honored to work with them.
So thank you, Jersey Mike's.
- Yeah, thank you, Jersey Mike's.
So what kind you got there?
- Oh, you know what?
I found a little turkey
and what do you have?
- I think I have an Italian
sort of roast beef situation here,
I'm not complaining about it.
- Well, let's do it.
We get to eat so much fun stuff
on the show, it's such a treasure.
- Okay, Jersey Mike's.
- Oh, it's so good.
- Thank you.
- Oh my gosh.
- We've can't both chew.
- It's so good.
Everybody, please enjoy your day.
Be safe, be good to each other.
Rage bake, watch TV, vote.
Be good to yourselves and each other.
Have some fun, have some laughs,
be serious and everything in between.
Thank you for allowing us to come
into your home and your life.
We're very honored to be a part
of it, thank you, good bye.
- [Ross] Yes Drew, well said.
(upbeat music)